un día de ajuste de cuentas para el
veterano de guerra vivo más condecorado
de Australia un tribunal de sidney
dictaminó que tres periódicos no
difamaron al ex soldado de élite de los
servicios aéreos especiales Ben Robert
Smith cuando informaron de su
implicación en los asesinatos de seis
prisioneros desarmados en Afganistán
entre 2009 y 2012 una reivindicación
para los periodistas que informaron de
la historia
para aquellos valientes hombres del país
que se levantaron y dijeron la verdad
sobre quién es Ben Roberts Smith un
criminal de guerra un matón y un
mentiroso Hoy es el Día de un poco de
Justicia para las víctimas afganas de
Ben Roberts Smith
Robert Smith Recibió la máxima
condecoración militar del país la cruz
Victoria en 2011 por su valentía en el
campo de batalla afgano pero en 2018 de
City morning Herald de Camera Times y de
Age publicaron informes en los que se le
acusaba de crímenes de guerra incluyendo
arrojar a un granjero esposado por un
acantilado y matarlo a tiros dispararon
prisionero por la espalda antes de tomar
su pierna prostética para un recipiente
para beber y ordenar al menos otros dos
asesinatos Robert Smith negó haber
cometido delito alguno y presentó una
demanda millonaria por daños y
perjuicios publicaron una historia de
esta magnitud Nunca es fácil pero el
periodismo de investigación de alta
calidad es vital para una democracia
prosperada
Robert Smith aún no se ha enfrentado a
cargos penales por los asesinatos se
espera más acciones legales mientras
Australia recapacita sobre su papel en
la guerra afgana una investigación
militar de 2020 descubrió que las
fuerzas especiales habían matado
ilegalmente a 39 prisioneros y civiles